I know a lot of people go out and they
find a local club with a DJ spinning I
believe is what they say yeah not old
freckles I go to sporting events to take
me out to the Speedway take me out to
the cars I'm an Indianapolis Indiana
home of the line and ass Indianapolis
Colts how they cheated they took a [ __ ]
hair out of the ball that's what we lost
by 35 unbelievable this is what I love
about Jim Irsay that bitching made his
stick and he works right there hey Jimmy
he's probably still up from last night
if you know what I mean anyways we're
gonna be going over to Indianapolis
Motor Speedway and e500 oh that's what
Indianapolis is home of the Motor
Speedway this old woman smoking
cigarettes is that a guy no it's a woman
I love the Midwest they haven't seen a
Surgeon General's report in their entire
life I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] smoking
cigarettes with some raw red meat in
their front shirt pocket well this
coffee's smiling I like Indianapolis
this guy's got a shovel oh he's filling
up the potholes and I got money out here
huh you'd never see that in LA oh I see
what they're doing the Indy 500s here so
that's they're filling up the potholes
they're making it look good alright so
right now we're on our way to the
Indianapolis Motor Speedway home of any
appleís 500 which is gonna be going down
this Memorial Day weekend what's amazing
about this Speedway is when you first
see you cannot [ __ ] believe how big
it is
cuz you forget that it has to be big
enough that people could be driving 200
miles an hour so we're gonna meet one of
the drivers who's gonna take me out on
the track I know who you think your
who's who's gonna drive you around bill
Rick Mears Gordon Johncock AJ Floyd now
none of those old coots half of them are
probably dead the one and only Danica
Patrick a lovely lady
do you realize how legendary this place
is I almost got the chills when I pulled
in here holy [ __ ] this is awesome
[Music]
alright Bilborough
Here I am Indianapolis Motor Speedway
with the legendary Danica Patrick gonna
take a lap and I'm gonna tell you right
now I hate being in the passenger seat
I'm definitely gonna get freaked out
do you get bored like after you do a
race you don't drive yourself home do
you like you know so you're just sitting
in stop-and-go traffic in like a Subaru
have you had like one of those Ricky
Bobby sort of uh rivalries with any
driver that even if he came in seventh
as long as they came in Atheist site
actually in racing that tends to be a
problem within teammates usually you
have the most similar equipment as they
do so it's the bigger test of talent
session with Lewis Hamilton and Nico
Rosberg there you go and for Milan it's
very very this is it right here this is
so iconic
I can't believe I'm here right now
you know what Aaron's notice about you
ste week like calm things around here
thank you and you just like you know you
can stay here you stay along the wall I
mean you're entering the corner at two
hundred thirty two hundred thirty five
miles an hour without lifting 235 miles
I'm pretty cool actually doesn't how
will you just ride right on somebody's
ass like that just knowing the whole
time that all someone has to do is just
just click you in the back and you're
gonna go flying into the wall you just
don't think about it right yeah I so
focused like I'm around this first week
of things
let's not something about those things
let's take this saying and you just come
up with that that's all I'm pretty sure
I didn't come up with it but I'm pretty
sure it's the stuff for sure it's the
saying but I use that with my wife it's
sure the honey I got any thoughts become
things I go too fast but I was thinking
I had speeded up a little bit
let me get the experience I went here in
95 and 96 I used to watch this every
year when I was growing up you know Rick
Mears yeah now unsub oh yeah
Mario Andretti see this is cool then he
come up along the wall now this must
feel like you're in like still in first
gear well I mean the car rolls around it
you know compared to the
oh yeah I thought I was gonna be nervous
but you're like so like calm how long
you been doing this this is my 27th
season of racing 27 and you're retiring
right I am that's awesome
thank you I'm so glad finally somebody's
like excited about me retiring like it's
my 11th still in your Prime like I don't
know how it works with racecar drivers
you know with athletes like you know
when you got to run around and stuff
your body breaks down and then it kind
of starts to get sad you're not as fast
how do you age out of racing I think
that you just don't care enough anymore
and there's so much a risk on the line
that you start thinking about that part
of it have you ever been driving like 20
miles an hour right on somebody's ask
someone right behind you and you just
start thinking about like going to the
mall or something menu is that when you
start thinking like I got to get out of
racing no I got what if they're gonna
make another anchorman they like wait a
minute I'm an Indy 500 right now I hope
they make another anchorman and Bob
anchorman like an all-time favorite of
mine I have kind of pictured you as like
the veronica corningstone
like all these people
she was like yet qualified what when is
your last race gonna be May 27 Sunday
May oh this is it
yeah it's in a few days oh my god this
so this is like a legendary trip around
or on the track with him how many miles
around business two and a half three and
a half miles around so it's a 200 laps
500 miles do you have any idea what lap
you're on after a while /if very
confused sometimes their parts in the
race and you're like brilliant left 35
or you're like holy crap how is it 40 to
go you know like there are certain
points in the race that go a lot faster
than other point I can't relate to that
as a comedian this night you go on stage
and you think and I must have done fifty
minutes and you've really been up there
for like 11 and but you somehow burn
through most of your act
they feel that my face getting pulled
over here is awesome
I literally I'm going twice as fast in
an IndyCar
double the speed oh that's how cool is
that now how do you how do you maintain
your calm when you're leading at a place
like this without thinking like don't
blow this well
I mean you you just get very singularly
focused you're thinking to yourself like
you know how does the car feel how do I
stay ahead of the balance how do I make
sure that I don't you know the front
stays hooked up and I don't let it get
you know too much understeer too fast
and then not be able to turn and then
you know what are the other cars doing
and you know looking in your mirrors
you'll send your spotter you're hearing
if anybody's off strategy you know
you're kind of I understood that a lot
going on with that I understood that was
awesome how fast were you going when
you're really going that's what we're
doing a twenty one thirty
I can't believe I just got to do that
that was so cool thank you so much yeah
of course all right there you go
legendary Indianapolis Motor Speedway I
want to thank Danica Patrick for not I
hid in a wall or anything like that it's
my dad
steely calm I thought I was gonna be
nervous I wasn't it was awesome
none of those tourists over there care
about me
[Music]
you